[Music]
I had a very clear understanding with
the Pentagon no guns
I'll carry your books I'll carry a torch
I'll carry a tune I'll carry on carry
over carry forward Cary Grant dashing
carry carry me back to old Virginny
now even Harry Caray if you show me how
but I will not carry a gun Alan Alda
Zrii ladle portrayal of army captain
Hawkeye Pierce in the iconic CB series
CBS series mash connected viewers to
life on the frontlines of war the Emmy
and Golden Globe winning actor has
worked in all genres he starred in
dramatic movies like The Aviator tackled
the politically charged role as a
senator on the west wing and taken
comedic turns in Tower Heist Alda also
hosted PBS is Scientific American
frontiers for 13 years he now teaches
acting techniques to scientists and
entrepreneurs to help them connect
better with their audiences and all the
hosts the podcasts clear and vivid
he says the ability to engage with
people clearly is the key to greater
understanding for everyone I agree with
that Alan Alda is with us this morning
for an announcement that he wants to
make so good to have you here it's great
to be here
how are you doing I'm doing great you
might be surprised to hear that when I I
tell him I haven't said in public until
now that I've been diagnosed with
Parkinson's disease and the reason that
I want to talk about it in public is
that it's I was diagnosed three and a
half years ago and I've had a full life
since then I've acted I've given talks I
helped at the oldest Center for
communicating science at Stony Brook I
started this new podcast and I noticed
that I've been on television a lot in
the last couple of weeks talking about
the new podcast and I could see my thumb
twitch in some shots and I thought it's
probably only a matter of time before
somebody does a story about this rather
sad third point of view that's not where
I am so this is the first time you're
revealing publicly that you've been
diagnosed with with Parkinson's disease
what was that diagnosis like when you
got it well it I I asked for a scan
because I thought I might have it I read
an article by Jane Brody in the New York
Times that indicated that if you have if
you act out your dreams yeah there's a
good chance you might that might be a
very early symptom that where nothing
else shows and act by acting out your
dreams I mean I was having a dream that
someone was attacking me and I threw a
sack of potatoes at them
what I was really doing is throwing a
pillow at my wife Wow Wow yeah so what
other what other what other symptoms did
you start to notice I didn't have any
symptoms the doctor said why do you want
to scan you don't have any symptoms and
I said I want to know if there's
anything I can do I wanted to do it
before things start to show up and so
months later a little twitch in my thumb
you know and the the thing I want folks
to know and this is not to shortchange
people who are suffering with really
severe symptoms you know symptoms can
get very bad and their families can
suffer but in the very beginning to be
immobilized by fear and think the worst
thing has happened to you it hasn't
happened to you still have things you
can do yeah I'm taking boxing lessons
three days a week I read three times a
week yeah I do
singles tennis a couple of times a week
I'm marched assume you because marching
to March music is good for Parkinson's
did you have a but did you I mean you
talk about the initial reaction to this
did you have an initial fear you know I
was mainly helping my family not be
worried yeah because it's common for us
all to go to the worst yeah but what's
interesting is this is dipped into the
disease that's different for almost
everybody who has it there is some
common symptoms but mostly everybody's
different and each day is different from
the next one day you wake up you think
oh it's over it's gone next day its back
the little words you don't know what
it's going to be but the main thing is
there's stuff you can do and and I'm
I've been you know how I look at
it's like a puzzle to be solved what do
I have to adapt to to carry on a normal
life do I enjoy solving puzzles really
fine well you have a remarkably
optimistic can-do attitude about a
disease that a lot of people are scared
about but also angry when they have your
staff says you have displayed no signs
of it may be here for Mike it's a
challenge
you know you you gotta cross the street
there cards coming how do you get across
the street you don't just sit on the
pavement and say well I guess I'll never
cross the street again you find a way to
do it people have all kinds of things
some people don't like it that they're
shorter than other people yeah so they
don't adapt to that yeah they're gonna
be unhappy so I mean I mean there are
there are people have really severe
symptoms that they have to face and
that's difficult it's not so difficult
to to say oh look I got I got a little
bit of a shake so you got a shake what's
interesting too is you're Alan Alda
Center essentially helps scientists
communicate complex topics in simple
terms and and including doctors and
nurses helping them communicate with be
excited by what would be kind of ironic
if I kept quiet about this right when I
have a center for communicating science
is named after me but I think I did
because I'm sort of well known it might
be helpful to people to hear the message
that there are things you can do you can
learn about things yeah and not follow
quackery but find out what real science
is coming up with that that helps it
helps to keep moving yeah it helps them
really what's if there's been anything
particularly challenging about this so
far for you what has it been you know I
think my saying something about it
publicly today is gonna make one thing a
little easier I'm not going to worry
while I'm trying to say something else
I'm not going to be thinking is my thumb
one a life of its own right you know
that's just one of the realities in my
life but I've acted in movies since I
was three and a half years since I had
that your diagnosis yeah and it hasn't
stopped my life at all I've had a richer
life than I've had up until now Wow you
are not just surviving this you are
thriving there are 1 million Americans
that have Parkinson's disease let's
finish it up to a million now so I
joined the fraternity until I hope
everybody who still can do something
it's busy doing things I'm going to
cover it on the podcast on my new
podcast clear vivid because I want to
spread the word thank you so much thanks
for having me thank you thank you